pourquoi un homme pourra
c'est-à-dire avoir une vie à
peu près tout
ali
venise italie
tél
deux hommes arrivent
merde boîte de merde et en
filigrane la liberté nous avons
dû se résigner à un long
combat des grands parcs et
jardins air canada a mis
l'emphase est mise en avant
vers 13h35 à rennes on n'arrive
pas à faire
intérêt poli
poursuit son tour de france
c'est jean-pierre raffarin qui
répondront aux questions de
jules claver aka
tous les grands dossiers
nationaux et régionaux
le terrain politique avec
jean-pierre raffarin affaire et
du poivre c'est lundi à 22h30
sur public sénat
bonjour réalité cette semaine
frédéric salat-baroux pour son
livre sur deux gaules et
pétards et puis henrique et
même les vaches mythe pour une
pièce intitulée quick qui
vendent des pommes
pourquoi
tous
avec navarro jours bonjour merci
d'être là
vous venez donc d'écrire un
livre consacré à la relation
entre de gaulle et pétanque ou
sous-titrés le destin la
blessure la leçon
qui est édité chez robert
laffont
peut donc que c'est une belle
voie là une ministre ouart de
cette relation entre deux hommes
qui ont
par définition
plus que d'autres marqué
l'histoire de notre pays
profondément
vous-même vous êtes
je vous avais été haut
fonctionnaire
vous avez été envoyées
revenir conseiller social à
l'élysée
elle met aussi secrétaire
général de la prison de la
république le président était
jacques chirac et de ses
d'ailleurs vous qui sur le
perron l'élysée a annoncé la
nomination de philippe de
villepin
comme premier
la ville de jérusalem
le cpe
note nous ramènera
inévitablement à l'actualité
mais aussi dans les jours où on
le pressent une actualité peta
avec que
la mise au jour de ces documents
ou qui sur le statut des juifs
on s'aperçoit que pétain avait
lui-même à noter pour durcir
le disque est urgent
en e ça n'est pas une
découverte car dans votre livre
cette année a raconté
c'est pas une découverte qui
est intéressant c'est qu'on
retrouve le document
en effet la façon dont pétain
on l'a corrigée de sa main là
cet est racontée par le
ministère fasse étrangères de
pétain de l'époque s'appelait
baudouin en 46 qui raconte la
scène
long conseil des ministres
pétain et le plus dur
ils exigent que les juifs soit
expédiée e-education nationale
donc là on a la traduction
par un document de ce qui se
savait
c'est-à-dire que pétain sans
la pression des allemands a
personnellement poussé au
statut des juifs
fond il a été le procureur du
logis d'antisémitisme d'état
si un des piliers du régime du
régime de vichy
et vous expliquait d'ailleurs
que
il y avait un fort côté
de revanche
les antidreyfusards dents la
naissance de l'état français
dans le même temps le régime
de vichy lui-même
et il peut vous raconter au fond
les prémices de ce qui va
devenir à vos yeux un couple
qui est un coup d'état selon
mûrement mûrement préparée
au fond qui est évident qu'il
ne fallait abattre la
république et c'est là c'est
la fameuse divine surprise
avec dans les années 30
toutes ces personnes
fondamentalement opposé
aussitôt de la révolution un
site d'égalité à la
république qui vont trouver en
pétard
un excellent porte-drapeau
politique
et lui-même pas changer dans
les années 30 le général
républicain
après son passage au
gouvernement parce qu'on voit
que la république est un danger
pour la france
hélas pas accepter dans son
entourage des gens comme
allibert rencontrer l'aval
et au fond devenir un
porte-drapeau de cette logique
contre-révolutionnaire
et c'est lui qui en 40
malgré son âge avec
l'énergique extraordinaire
elle va passer à l'acte il va
effectivement à la fois prendre
le pouvoir
et conduire ce qui est un
véritable coup d'état alors
renversé la verépublique et
puis instaurer un régime
de type salazariste
c'est-à-dire autorités
r non républicain corporatisme
dans la turbulente
là la bague au doigt je sais
qu'elle dit 'cette joint la
tutelle de pékin à cesser le
combat le 18 juin à l'appel du
général de gaulle
après la guerre de gaule
des crêtes pour conclure
l'état français cette
période-là été
comment dire une forme de
parenthèse une fiction que la
république n'a jamais cessé
d'exister ce qui est possible
ce que le turc chile amd de
gaule à happart faire vivre
d'ailleurs la république a
continué de vivre à travers le
les français résistant puis à
travers le conseil national de
la résistance etc
mais vous étiez à l'élysée
auprès de jacques chirac
lorsque jacques chirac au fond a
mis fin à cette doctrine qui
avait été une doctrine
que le pays jusqu'à françois
mitterrand était la doctrine
officielle de la france
alors comment
même si je ne sais quel est
votre regard sur cette se
susurre tournant majeur malgré
tout dans notre façon de voir
l'histoire
quel a été le discours de
jacques chirac au vel d'hiv
le discours du vel d'hiv et vous
avez raison un tournant
politique majeur
la logique du général de gaule
à l'aller
absolument juste pour l'époque
c'est-à-dire il ya un vrai coup
d'état
du maréchal pétain de la falda
libère
qui renverse la république et
donc ya une inégalité
fondamentale contrairement à ce
que tous ce qui a pu être dit
dans le régime de vichy
et deux goals
effectivement t-shirt child
reconnaît seule continue dit
vous êtes solitude je vous
reconnais seul
enfin seule assumer pendant un
temps la république puis avoir
le soutien du conseil national a
adopté la résistance
e et aussi des partis comme le
parti socialiste et notamment
celle de bloom donc il a raison
en 45 de considérer que c'est
une parenthèse vichy est une
parenthèse qui n'est pas une
parenthèse légale et en plus
dans un pays qui a été c'est
largement
c'est une façon fond de
souligner que non la france n'a
pas été
pour le pétainiste n'a pas
été dans la défaite et que la
république dans sa continuité
a été dans le camp des
vainqueurs
donc politiquement c'est à la
fois juste et si absolument
essentiel
pour remettre la france debout
juste après la guerre
là où effectivement jacques
chirac le gaulliste franchi un
pas
tiens pas il ment c'est que lui
20' sur un autre terrain
qui un terrain qui ne le ressens
de fer qui est fondamentalement
pragmatique
ils voient bien que la blessure
de vichy 2
estimant que ce que pour la
communauté juive
mais c'est pas vrai il n'y a pas
une abstraction
de vichy
c'est quatre mille cinq cents
policiers
étrange uniforme de policier
français qui sont pas arrivées
qui ont raflé
des familles juives et qui ont
été déportés et bien souvent
ne sont pas revenus
et donc là
le mythe politique
elle crée par les gaullistes et
les communistes ne correspond
pas à ça
d'où une blessure qui est
absolument immense
et c'est là que la parole
présidentielle est essentiel
en nommant les choses
en disant oui les fonctionnaires
l'état français
euros ont été les complices du
régime nazi
au fond il nomme et ils apaisent
et c'est là que il va au-delà
de la doctrine gaulliste en
considérant que la nécessité
d'apaiser cette blessure en
nommant les gens
et en nommant les choses et
supérieur
à l'intérêt politique qui
s'est fidèles qui dans le temps
c'était évidemment atténuer
de 45 et d'ailleurs ce qui est
intéressant c'est que au
contraire du discours du vel
d'hiv il ya deux discours de
chirac il faut voir ensemble le
premier level 10 95
et le dernier quasiment 2005 et
en tirant mage au juste au
panthéon
c'est quasiment son dernier
discours
et qui veut dire par rapport à
cette réflexion sur l'histoire
et la mémoire
oui la france une certaine
manière ces des hommes auraient
été complices de l'occupant
mais il ya eu aussi des
français absolument formidable
de toutes origines de toutes
classes sociales
qui eux se sont levés solecki
ont pris tous les risques pour
protéger les juifs
donc on est
au niveau du général de gaulle
face à une doctrine politique
et au niveau de jacques chirac
sur quelque chose qui est
différent
nommer les choses et au fond
écrire l'histoire telle qu'elle
a été pour pouvoir apaiser on
est sur un autre terrain
politique
c'est le verbe qui apaise alors
que le général de gaulle
c'était la doctrine qui permet
de relancer le pays
et ce qui est intéressant c'est
que ça soit un gaulliste qui
les fait
mais ça c'est tout à fait
chirac absolument
e d'ailleurs on voit que cette
question vous offrons est à
l'origine de ce livre
une zone de compétence et la
question posée d'entrée de jeu
en disant
de qui sommes nous les enfants
mais à ce que nous sommes les
enfants plutôt dé des
français pétainiste de deux
ans ce qui ont raccompagné le
maréchal
puisque tard le but
ou bien les enfants de la de la
résidence existante c'est une
question pour vous
vous vous posez à vous-même
mais coup vous renvoyez aussi
pour cent au cours collectifs je
pense qu'elle se pose
à nous tous français et à
chacun d'entre nous en tant
qu'homme ou femme
nous tous parce que
nécessairement la blessure est
absolument hallucinant
le plus la france
considérée comme la plus
grande puissance militaire en 40
s'effondre en quelques jours
pour le renverse la république
basculé dans le camp
l'occupante de villarreal
colabor
e et marne elle participe vous
pouvez le lire on rafle
c'est-à-dire commet
l'irréparable comment le pays
des droits de l'homme de la
révolution française de ses
idéaux peut faire ça donc là
une question fondamentale sur
notre nature profonde
et puis ya une question qui est
élevé qui renvoyé par les
deux hommes et qui est
complètement intemporel c'est
la question
pétain porte au fond unité de
séparation
il ya des moments
on n'a pas le choix
la france est vaincu froid bien
collaboré pour protéger ses
sources hamza al-bahlul 17
de gaule ces une autre logique c
on a toujours le choix
des dons qui renvoient chacun de
nous
notamment dans l'adversité à
cette question fondamentale
est-ce qu'on pense qu'on a
toujours le choix
y a des moments il faut
soumettre
au rapport de forces est en sa
que c'est une question qui se
pose à la fois aux français
c'est quoi l'identité de la
france
à travers cet accident lorsque
ce drame
terrible de 40
et puis à chacun d'entre nous
quelle vision de la vie honda
et ce qui est intéressant c'est
que ces deux hommes
qui porte d'aix
vision de la france
diamétralement opposés à
partir de 40 et au fond des
visions de la vie totalement
opposé
se sont rencontrés de 30 ans
avant 19 112 on était très
proches
et c'est ça qui m'a fasciné
c'est-à-dire cet extraordinaire
roman français
la puissance romanesque
extraordinaire qui est d'une
très grande proximité de ce
que de gaulle écrit même pour
peu de temps pour écrire
d'abord ya sept rencontres
pétain qui n'aime personne qui
est un colonel à deux ans de la
retraite complètement
placardisé comme on dirait
aujourd'hui
de gaulle arrive par hasard dans
son régiment haras
il sort de saint-cyr hélas une
rencontre extrêmement fort
pétain qui n'aime personne qui
est très dur
on voit tout de suite en lui qui
est en face quelqu'un
d'absolument exceptionnelle
% et là effectivement conti
devient maréchal de france qui
décide rentre à l'académie
française pour succéder à son
grand effet les rivales foche
il se dit j'ai besoin d'une
plume
et là il se souvient
qui l'a connue celle cet homme
exceptionnel le le jeune de goal
qui devient effectivement à la
fois son collaborateur
préférées sa plume
et plus fondamentalement
quelqu'un qui compte peu de gens
comptaient pour peta de gaulle
compter
est-ce qu'il était le fils qui
l'aurait voulu avoir
peut-être même l'homme qui
l'auraient voulu m parce qu'il
perçoit les similitudes entre
eux
mais aussi les grandes
différences
de gaulle à une culture qui
absolument exceptionnel que
pétain n'a pas
et il a une fois dans l'action
et est dans l'énergie et dans
le dynamisme que pétain qui est
profondément pétainiste
pétainiste et pessimiste dont 6
mixte pessimiste
le luna park
donc y'a quelque chose il ya
quelque chose avec un rapport
dissymétrique pétards ne
cessera jamais des mets de
boules malgré la rivalité
extrêmement violente entre eux
alors que de gaulle ces
différentes
il a toujours admiré le soldat
l'homme le militaire de grande
qualité
mais fondamentalement c'est pas
un disque de pétain de même au
début
cindy site de fauche
il croit que l'énergie permet
de renverser les rapports de
force et c'est en ça qui sont
fondamentalement différents
avec des similitudes
jusqu'en 40 puisque la et l'eau
dans les années 30 on
construira un parcours
d'ambition
extrêmement fort pour arriver
à être pour le moment tout le
monde s'effondre on attendait m
demandez-le on entendait rénaux
toute la classe politique ces
fonds de ces ces deux hommes
s'étaient connus 30 ans avant
qui vont passer à l'acte
et qui vont là et l'eau d'une
certaine manière on veut
prendre le pouvoir
mais derrière et au delà de
cette capacité à prendre le
pouvoir
ces deux hommes font de
conception de la vie
extrêmement différents
et ensuite qui vont conduire
deux parcours politique
diamétralement opposées
travailler la puissance
romanesque injoignable
extraordinary à 12 heures de
nuit évidemment inspiré pour
écrire ce
ce nouveau pépin juste un mois
avant qu'on ne se quittent
frédéric salat-baroux
donc je disais vous aviez été
à l'élysée
le secrétaire général au
moment du cpe etc comment
votre livre se conclut sur eux
une sorte de
en e des loges du modèle
français a d'ailleurs
face à l'atout ce qui a abouti
au pompon c'est que
pour l'emporter le moment la
date du 3 mai dernier etc
donc en quoi cette espèce d'
acte de foi un peu vos listes un
peu comme que vous l'euro
reflète à la fois à la fin du
livre
comment vous jugez les
événements actuels
vous voulez vivez comment
évident que je crois maintenant
que j'ai
oui enfin compris on est jamais
loin quand ton art quand on
arrive j'ai écrit ce livre
parce que bourges est
fondamentalement une passion
pour une passion pour la france
et son modèle % et je suis je
suis d'origine étrangère suis
pas les français donc la france
représente quelque chose
et à travers eux le parcours
des deux hommes c'est une façon
d'exprimer cette passion dans le
modèle français
évidemment la crise a montré
on pensait qu'il était
complètement dépassé est-ce
qu'on a vu ce qui a permis au
pays de mieux tenir peu d'autres
modèles face à la crise qu'on
a connu
dans les deux dernières années
alors vous m'interrogez sur
trois heures très brièvement
parce que notre temps et aider
sur la crise et en même temps
dans dans ce modèle français
de m l'art et la manière de
panique s'était aussi bas
niveau wim
y aller il y a une spécificité
de l'année et mais depuis la
révolution française et de ses
problèmes inhérents au génie
français
mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que contrairement à ce qui a pu
être dit c'est un pays qui est
tout-à-fait réformable
il faut du temps il faut de la
pédagogie ça peut être très
difficiles comme la période
qu'on connaît mais la france
absolument un format court
prônant un peu distant sur la
réforme des retraites
on est temps qu'on l'a fait
on l'a fait et puis
on l'a où on l'a fait en
plusieurs étapes
93 edwards à la dure la fed
pour 100 e
pour l'ol pour les pour le
privé
en terre en 2004 on le fait à
la fois
pour le privé et public qui on
dépasse 40 40 ans de
cotisations
en 2008 on fait des régimes
spéciaux
élan franchi une autre étape
on verra comment les
événements se déroulent et on
va se prendre des coups francs m
voilà donc sur cette base que
malgré tout un petit peu petit
dix personnes seulement c'est un
pays qui est parfaitement
réformable
et tout à fait prêt à le
faire
merci entre copains mercier au
niveau de gaulle pétanque
ça repart
le rythme annuel de flottement
jour pour jour merci d'être
avec nous
vous nous offrez cette fois un
minivan contre 3 un pendant 3 ou
il ya dans le livre que vous
habitez
en ce moment chez albin-michel
ya une première partie
qui s'appelle
quand je pense que beethoven est
mort
alors que tant de crétins
vivent
vous avez bien dit on ne dirait
pas la place tahrir
m dans la dernière partie du
milliard de la pièce qui qui
vendent des preuves qui étayent
actuellement jouée au théâtre
la bruyère
et daniel le brun comme
interprète principale d cela
fait apparaître les yeux
et puis entre les deux il ya un
disque
un disque de morceaux que vous
avez choisi de béton
à fait que l'ouverture de
coriolan un morceau de fidelio
évidemment un passage de
l'hymne à la joie et d'autres
morceaux qui vous sont chères
et d'ailleurs il faut le lire le
la première partie du livre
en écoutant
parce que oui le livre tel qu'il
est écrit il est en même temps
scandé oui par les morceaux que
vous nous faites vous mieux
comprendre d'ailleurs en anglais
racontant aussi
pour ce pays qui accompagnent
notre démarche
mais évoque démarche
singulière en ce sens que pour
cent vous nous expliquer que les
les les musiciens
parce que ce livre sur béton
suite un livre sur mozart et
précède un livre sur mac les
chômeurs dont vous êtes
vraiment dans la musique
vous expliquez que ce sont des
des maîtres de vie oui dd sorte
de guide alors comment en
arriver vous leur faveur les
joueurs visés la flûte et
c'est tout ce que j'avais deux
originaires et bien sûr la
musique parce que je vais pas en
parler un musicologue
au musicien
plus vraiment parler comme rome
et pour cent et efficace que il
sait que tu mens bon
pour moi comme pour beaucoup de
gens
la musique a joué un rôle
fondamental dans ma vie dans ma
vie spirituelle c'est-à-dire
que
le pouvoir de la musique c'est
nous atteindrons rendent souvent
des raisonnements en dessous des
concepts
pourtant son entendement
un endroit où on ressent
on les trouve
on a des sentiments on a des
émotions
et c'est tout
émotionnel de la musique me
paraît très important parce
que
la musique
pacifique la musique apaise et
de la musique redynamiser de la
musique console
à la halle le pouvoir aussi de
de déplacés à nos frontières
intérieures
par le biais de de l'émotion
mais si elle touche aussi pauvre
de moi ça veut dire que la
musique tient
un discours 2
deux devis un discours de
sagesse alors quand vous crevez
trouvait béton l'amf actes que
vous avez
passionnément aimée
à l'adolescence elle pour le
retrouver à l'occasion d'une
exposition sans vous vous
baladez vous tombez sur un
masque de détails plus tard
de vous restituer ensuite quand
on écoute en même temps qu on
voulait vous restituer les
émotions première rencontre
la négraille l'énergie est
venu de se saisir
prochain rdv vers clients
étrangers
et ça c'est le premier stade
mais ensuite vous allez au
climat
m et donc pour vous en tirez
presque ce que ça change votre
regard sur la vie
finalement
c'est un peu comme le veut la
rencontre avec un autre être
humain
complètement peut changer
l'autre c'est ça votre regard
c'est une vraie rencontre est
d'ailleurs un avant et un après
marqué par la rencontre
effectivement dès que c'est
quelqu'un qui m'aime pas
à lviv qui mettent à penser e
la neuvième symphonie
e comme testament la même si la
crème corps quelques quatuor
après
et quelque chose qui me
bouleverse parce que cet homme
qui a eu une vie épouvantables
né dans un foyer heureux avec
un père violent une mère
effacés
l'idée avec bic
% et connaissant la surdité à
26 28 ans ne connaissant pas
l'amour partagé parce qu'il ne
veut pas imposer son infirmité
à une femme sa surdité cet
homme si malheureux nous laisse
comme testament un hymne à la
joie
alors je me suis dit
il a compris quelque chose que
moi je n'ai pas compris et c'est
pour ça il m'a forcée à
réfléchir
outre que je reçois la musique
et pour cause de coup d'état
mais je comprends ce que je vois
c'est à dire que la joie
c'est un rapport
hi-media
à ce qui nous entoure
ces contrats la tristesse ça
c'est pas nouveau
mais la tristesse c'est quoi
c'est le mans
manque de quelque chose au
passé et qui a disparu manque
de peu d'avenir de projets
elle manque au présent
la tristesse et vivre sa vie sur
le mode du mans où la joie
c'est vivre sa vie et sur le
mode du plein
se satisfaire
d'être se réjouir d'exister
que les autres existent
être content de ce que l'on a
et non pas rêver dede d'autres
choses
et ça se sait si c'est une
vraie transformation spirituelle
ce que je constate de nous on a
la capacité de vivre la même
situation
sur le mode
ou de la tristesse après
impôts de la joie
et des termes choisis
mais si nous et saura tristesse
parfois
et la joie qui s'est un peu de
fil conducteur à votre
l'autre pomme première partie
du du livre donc
et vous vous écrivez une sorte
d'ode à l'optimisme pour le
mode car beaucoup ri mais alors
quand on lit heureux les raisons
d'être optimistes de son
investissement
fleurissement amorcée c'est sur
le fil du rasoir sidérurgie il
veut être optimiste parce que
c'est la seule solution que le
désespoir me souffle
pourquoi
c'est-à-dire que
je crois qu'effectivement mais
il ya un certain optimisme est
mort on va t'il ème siècle je
dirais
à l'issue de la deuxième
guerre mondiale quand on
découvre les camps
et quand on fait le calcul deux
millions de morts
kiki adjani dans cette danse
demi-siècle
cet optimisme est celui il rêve
du 19e siècle
de philosophie d'histoire c'est
à dire
l'humanité s'améliorer
on peut pas penser que
l'humanité s'améliore
moralement content
découvreur % chips
et éthiques
la grande culture du de la
deuxième moitié du 20e siècle
a dit plutôt pessimiste voire
désespérée
mais voilà en même temps c'est
comme toute culture dominante
ça devient intense et ça
devient un préjugé
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui les
gens
le livre qui liste étant
spécialiste de la bouche
pour cent de la direction du
progrès donc beaucoup parlé
voilà
la notion de progrès qui est
aujourd'hui complètement de
dévaluer dévaloriser mais en
même temps donc bon contenu en
deux
de vivre et de profiter mais
c'est à dire quand cette
en sport le figaro avec un
progrès des sciences et des
techniques
n'y a pas de progrès de la
moralité ces hommes ne sont pas
meilleure aujourd'hui et qui
hier ont connu l'époque de
platon
donc faut abandonner cette idée
et je disais construire un
optimisme le moderne et nous
avons jeté sous la forme d'un
credo parler de salles
seulement quelques librairies
cité d'ailleurs ap
et pour cent et donc qui
c'est pour vous dire que c'est
sérieux
le sens aigu de la douleur je me
sens seule
profondes ce qui va pas
qui me pousse à être optimiste
c'est-à-dire que pour moi
l'optimisme et le pessimisme
partis du même constat ça ne
va pas
le monde est mauvais
douloureux
on n'y souffre
et il est chiant chacun une
réaction à ça
les pessimistes consorts
je dirais aux forces négative
et d'optimisme
d'abord distinguer ce qui n'est
pas un but qui dépend pas des
buts n'est pas stupide
et il sur la partie qui dépend
de moi je relève mémoire mais
manche
donc que l'optimisme je dirais
que c'est l'intelligence qui
s'allie avec le courage
pour dire
pour 100 e année améliorant ce
ce qui peut être amélioré
et j avoue moi j'existe
j'ai envie mais avec d'autres de
de réévaluer
la semos nothing is me laisse ce
mouvement
et ebay tolosan il m'a aidé à
former tous
taylor dent dans cette promenade
avec des tops et avec sa musique
donc puisque encore une fois le
discuter il est avec nous
y a aussi des une promenade dans
dans notre univers culturel un
petit peu l'état
alors que vous avez un regard un
petit peu critique
c'est un communiqué
balmont mavua toujours il faut
porter de cette fameuse formule
de 2 gigas
bilan on ne fait pas de bonne
littérature avec de bons
sentiments et on vous montrait
très bien commencé a été
transformée par an
quand on est des bons sentiments
effet de l'amazighité actuelle
est mauvaise en fait la bonne
course cette équipe sait pas du
tout ce que voulait dire je ne
travaillais plus du parti auto
pas d'auto défense parce que
vous n'avez pas défendre et à
un peu
elle prépare à la règle
la traduit dans
de cinquantaine de pays en 43
langues dont
vous êtes vous avez là de la
certitude celui qui sait que son
public est là c'est pas gai
représente néanmoins voilà
mais néanmoins
j'ai pas tous très soulagés
les combats
c'est-à-dire que
en e
% la faculté d'écrire
elle vient non pas de sentiment
qu'on éprouve pour moi j'aime
bien cet été dans les musées
une histoire une phrase une
pensée
les deux est de créer un lien
avéré avec le lecteur
tout ça n'a rien à voir avec
la morale comme exprimant peut
exprimer une morale
épouvantable
être un écrivain divin comme
le marquis de sade
la flotte et on peut avoir une
très belle morale
et être un écrivain divin
comme syndicaliste
donc tout cela tout cela est
elle est source c'est-à-dire
que
sap est en fait c'est assez
symptomatique de coin de notre
époque de notre époque
pour s'enfuir et de se donner
une prime
au pessimisme
je dirai au cynisme aussi été
au nihilisme
aujourd'hui quand vous lisez pas
exempt de critiques de donner
des cours de théâtre
on parle de danse sublime au
dessus de la dune on parle d'une
réjouissante noirceur qui offre
une mise en abyme de les relouer
sears a fait florès oui parce
que la ville attire excellent
moi ce que je veux juste dire
attention on se rend plus compte
de ce qu'on dit
c'est-à-dire cette vieille
langue
de bois c'est-à-dire
ces idéologies excès on a mis
des lunettes et on sait plus que
d'une certaine couleur
je ne sais plus quand même une
cible d'attentats
et on prend le score voit
traverser le net
pour la réalité même
donc
doudou c'est cet appel est
paradoxale et précis quand
même rare
un optimisme devant le but
et alors lui qui termine par un
autre
là le texte de la pièce donc
que kiki van beethoven qui est
pour cent au fou dont vous dites
qu'au fond elle a été à
l'origine de votre
de votre démarche parce qu'on
ait retrouvé évidemment des
tops et qui est un des acteurs
de poids peut-être que cette
pièce l'héroïne est en jeu
dame qui est maintenant en
maison de retraite si vous avez
des montréalais
à la fois juste et tendre un
pour les les gens qui sont dans
les maisons de retraite que vous
peut-on parler aux adolescents
oui ainsi vous avez cinq ou dix
ans en bande
il parle plus de sexualité
qu'ils ne le font vraiment
et pour cent
et ils sont quelques pas
sur les berges de de la vie et
donc ils sont aussi très
moqueur
pour 100 e et en même temps et
doivent rendre des comptes à
leurs familles dans ce cas cette
série pour autant les
adolescents de composer mais m
évidemment les musées
éliminer les personnes rendent
compte
à des gens qui sont plus jeunes
qu'elle et qui sont beaucoup
plus
ennuyeuse que leurs propres
parents
donc il y as et il ne cesse
d'être en marge des faits tout
en se drapant dokic et la bêta
26 tours d'une femme qui a
l'apparence d'un bien
pour le poste de contrôle
installé à 6 2 passes
si ce ne sont des cheftaines
mieux de ses copines
et enceinte
mais c'est une morte vivante
c'est-à-dire que diarra chagrin
athènes n'a pas osé aborder
et donc
% elle flotte
et la musique
à l'arrivée
parce que la musique va la
chercher là où ça fait mal
c'est la musique de beethoven
elle va quand même se font
raser
pas de guérir je dirais par la
musique et guérir ses amis et
en arabe a changé la vie de ces
animaux étaient trois copines
complètement
ils sont avec lui
mais parce qu'elles vont grâce
à la musique allez ok allez
plongez dans une motion
parfois il faut faire les
preuves de l'extrême tristesse
pour en tirer comme un jus
la joie où le bonheur
mais par contre si on ne pense
pas en face de qui nous fait
souffrir
si on se tient à l'écart on se
tient à l'écart de soi et on
se tient à l'écart des
existences j'étais d'ailleurs
de concert de bonheur de
mi-mandat
ce type se tenir à l'écart des
émotions et des passions pour
ne pas souffrir ses modalités
dudu s'estimait pas
5 e donc j'aimerais moi ma mère
dit le sage tibétains
pour moi souffrir de la mort de
ma mère
et puis ya le modèle
d'estoniens je veux dire qui est
allé le gbm est intensément
quitte à souffrir énormément
mais à tirer de cette
souffrance peut-être
pour une leçon de vie et qui me
fera encore plus aimer l'amour
fou ou aimer la vie
donc
ces fameuses rendez-vous avec
l'intensité des émotions
et elles vont guérir
elle voit arriver à la joie
mais ça sera en passant par par
rapport à pas par la douleur
on sait qui est qui qui vont de
paire de gants pour donner au
théâtre la bruyère à paris
est-ce que maintenant que vous
êtes plongés parce que on vous
imagine totalement écrivant
tout cela immergé dans la
musique de béton
parce que maintenant vous êtes
plongé à user de balles déjà
en août pas encore le maillot
oui c'est exactement ce que vous
avez fait - et donc vous allez
comme sa ville
vous immerger complètement pour
s oui parce que ça m'énerve
parce que parce que la lnr la
musique est plutôt des grands
compositeurs me font penser des
choses que je ne penserai pas à
son aise
battu par exemple c'est une
qualification de demain soir
c'est d'ailleurs quelqu'un je
détestais quand j'étais jeune
et que je n'avais pas la foi
ensuite il m'a impressionné
quand j'ai commencé à avoir la
foi
et qui maintenant med
à construire cette fois donc
c'est aussi ça c'est un rapport
qui est et c'est pas fini il ya
beaucoup de choses à dire pour
et j'attends encore création
d'actifs je suis sûre que
une réserve des surprises
et en même temps où il ya
beaucoup de traces de dieu dans
vos écrits dessus en voiture
sur betclic très décomplexée
par rapport à cela
je parle très facilement
de dieu parce que
c'est parce que j'ai fait
à je passais pas toutes les
couleurs de l'arc-en-ciel
ci-dessus est actée dans une
famille athée
devenu l'étudiant philosophie
puis professeur de philosophie
et
en plus cette dérive à
l'école normale supérieure
je suis agnostique et
aujourd'hui et puis à 29 morts
ont juré dans le jeu je reçois
la fois
donc aujourd'hui je me
considère comme un agnostique
croyants
pour ce qui est aussi un
paradoxe menu avec six morts
c'est-à-dire que
amnesty parce que si on me
demande si dieu existe je
réponds je ne sais pas
mais j'ajoute
mais je crois que oui
parce qu'il me paraît très
très important de bien